depuis ces dernières semaines elles ont
fleuri dans le centre ville de tours 8
boutiques vendant du cbd du cannabis
dont l'un des constituants du cannabis à
l'eau et européennes l'autorisent la
législation française est plus floue les
conditions de commercialisation restent
néanmoins stricte interdit à fumer il
est toléré sous forme alimentaire ou
produits dérivés uniquement explications
de romain delville ça ressemble à de
l'herbe à fumer ça en à l'odeur la
texture mais celle ci est légal à la
vente pourquoi parce qu'elle ne contient
pas de th et ou si peu la substance
stupéfiante
c'est de la fleur de cbd pour cannabis
viol est officiellement au nom de la loi
elle ne se fume pas la législation nous
interdit en fait de parler de combustion
donc ici nous à la galerie du chambre on
parle que pour en fusion c'est un
produit qui est destiné à la
consommation alimentaire et non à la
combustion dans cette boutique ouverte
il ya un peu plus d'un mois le chanvre
se décline sous toutes ses formes
il y a les cosmétiques aux chambres les
bonbons aux chambres les gélules la
bière aux chambres des sacs à dos ou
encore l'huile deux chambres présenté
comme thérapeutique
c'est un extrait de graines de cannabis
donc ça va on va être plus sur un
traitement de fond ça va être pour des
personnes qui vont être qu'ils vont voir
de l'arthrose qui vont avoir de
l'anxiété des problèmes de sommeil mais
des problèmes assez récurrent rien qu'à
tours 8 boutiques ont fleuri dans la
ville et si la vente de chanvre est
autorisé il est toujours interdit de le
cultiver en france le cannabis light
provient donc de l'agriculture de suisse
ou d'italie